well ladies and gentlemen we had
primaries last night and as expected
wyoming republican congresswoman liz
cheney has been
absolutely brutally defeated
in her republican primary
did she abandon republican orthodoxy was
she pro-choice or against lowering taxes
on the rich or any policy it nope it
wasn't anything like that
she simply said that donald trump really
did lose the election in 2020 and for
that
the maga people determined that she had
to be punished and she will now be
replaced on the november final general
election ballot by harriet hageman
an individual whose political views are
essentially identical to liz cheney's
with the exception that harriet hageman
has parroted the claim
that joe biden
didn't really win in november of 2020
and that apparently was a mortal sin
let's talk about last night's primaries
as the associated press reports trump
for cheney loses wyoming gop primary
ponders 2024 bid i don't even care about
the 2024 thing for now she was on with
savannah guthrie this morning and sort
of said i'm going to think about 24.
there's no real need to talk about that
right now a lot of things will happen
between now and then uh liz cheney
trump's fiercest republican adversary
writes the ap
in in congress soundly lost a republican
primary failing the falling to a rival
backed by the former president in a
route that reinforced his grip on the
party's base
the third term congresswoman and her
allies entered tuesday downbeat about
her prospects
and listen she lost i mean i don't even
really know what else we need to pull
from this she lost and she lost very
very significantly
and the reason that she became a target
of the maga people and of donald trump
is that she insisted
trump didn't win in 2020. trump really
genuinely lost she's still a republican
she still voted the way trump uh uh
wanted
93 of the time when she was in congress
and trump was president
but she says no trump genuinely did lose
and in her concession speech sort of her
her speech that she gave
she says
i easily won last time i could have won
again i just would have had to lie and
say that trump won and i wasn't willing
to do that let's listen to what she had
to say last night
two years ago i won this primary with 73
of the vote true
i could easily have done the same again
the path was clear
but it would have required that i go
along with president trump's lie about
the 2020 election right it would have
required that i enable his ongoing
efforts to unravel our democratic system
and attack the foundations of our
republic
that was a path i could not and would
not take
the lincoln project commented on liz
cheney's primary loss that's a group
made of sort of non-trump republicans
for the most part and they said tonight
marks the end of the republican party
what remains shares the name of the
republican party but it is in fact an
authoritarian nationalist cult dedicated
only to donald trump so there's really
two sides to this
is it wacky and is it disturbing
that this is what the republican party
has become of course it is of course
it's wacky and disturbing the goal of
the maga people is to purge the
republican party of the critics of
donald trump even something as benign as
saying the results were the real results
joe biden did win donald trump did lose
you've got adam kinzinger retiring liz
cheney lost her primary some of the
other republicans who did vote to
convict trump on that second impeachment
trial are either retiring or lost
primaries so
it is absolutely crazy that that's the
situation at the same time
it's important to remind you that
liz cheney mostly voted with trump and
she's being replaced by someone who will
mostly vote in the way that trump would
want will vote with the republican party
whatever
harriet hageman will vote the same way
as liz cheney on just about every issue
the only difference is hegemon is
willing to repeat the big lie whereas
liz cheney was not so it's also
disturbing because on policy
there is essentially no difference
between hegemon and cheney they're both
against abortion they're both for you
know lower taxes for the rich whatever
the difference is actually just one
about this issue where it's about an
election that was almost two years ago
so that's also sad now these results
could potentially backfire and i'll
mention the way in which that could
happen
wyoming's total population is 580 000.
no i'm not saying 580 000 people voted
yesterday i'm not saying there's 580 000
republicans the total population of
wyoming is 580 000
tiny electorate
much more subject
to
having a primary manipulated by out of
state money and trump and the maga
people these results could send a signal
to the more reasonable republicans in
other parts of the country to the extent
that they they exist and to a little
extent they do
that the republican party is now the
maga party and many republicans aren't
at all in favor of this being a maga
party if you're mitt romney for example
it is at this point thanks to the
democratic party that was we still even
have some semblance of democracy in the
united states but if you're romney you
should understand that your own party
will come for you at least potentially
and
we have to see what the impact is of
that on to the extent that they exist
the more moderate and reasonable
republicans now couple other elections
from last night lisa murkowski also was
challenged by a pro-trump republican in
alaska in the senate
she won enough votes to advance to the
general election in november in that
senate race
and sarah palin although she did not get
the most votes in her alaska
congressional uh primary yesterday
um she also will advance uh to november
so
that's what's going on and we're gonna
have these are it's an open house seat
for sarah palin and we will see in
november what happens with that but
very disturbing results that's for sure
one of our long time sponsors splendid
spoon is giving you 50 dollars off as
many of you know i am not vegetarian but
i think eating plant-based
is a great thing and i do more of it
consciously
splendid spoon takes the work out of
eating plant-based by delivering
ready-to-eat plant-based meals smoothies
and juices right to your door splendid
spoon fits into my day easily the meals
are in my fridge put them on the
stovetop or in the microwave and i've
got a great fresh plant-based meal in a
few minutes it saves me time which is
really useful right now
whether you're vegan or you just want to
add an easy delicious way to have more
plants in your diet splendid spoon is a
great way to go there are great dishes
like creamy mushroom and spinach noodles
coconut curry cauliflower tikka soup
that's one of my favorites tons of
choices the menu rotates constantly i've
tried a lot of different meal
subscription services splendid spoon is
great on both taste and quality they
pack so much flavor into the dishes they
taste freshly cooked splendid spoons
smoothies are awesome when i'm on the go
and you'll get 50 off your first week
when you subscribe at splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below